Hi, this is Maria
Plummer, and this
lecture is on the
pathology of thrombosis
in kind of comparison
to hemorrhage.
These are the learning
objectives, and
this is kind of the
track we're going
to take if you want
to follow along.
The other word for some
condition that causes
thrombosis is also
thrombophilia, like
love of thrombi,
Philadelphia being the city
of brotherly love.
So just if I mention
thrombophilia, it's
basically the same thing.
The definition is
pretty straightforward.
If you have a
blood clot in a
vessel and that
stops the natural
blood flow, that will
lead to a problem.
usually some type
of obstruction.
And whether or not
that causes mortality
or morbidity depends
on where this
blood clot is or
how big it is or
what organ or place
it's blocking off.
This is important
because when we discuss
the cardiac system and
you've discussed the
nervous system already,
we have to realize
that the thrombosis
-associated deaths, especially
in the United States,
the top ones are
myocardial infarctions
and strokes or cerebral
vascular accidents.
And we need to
understand that to
understand those diseases. So
this is a very important
concept, the Virchow
triad, which I think
he was a German
pathologist, although
don't quote me on that.
You need these three
factors kind of to work
together for thrombosis
to occur, although
having one of them
can help too. The most
important is the
endothelial injury, which is
why it's on top. And
when endothelial cells,
the lining of the
vessels are injured,
that will do a lot of
different things. One
thing is that it changes
the local blood flow
and it's going to
affect coagulability,
which we'll discuss in
a second. Abnormal blood
what do I mean? Stasis,
slowing of blood,
turbulence,
and I will go into
these a little bit more.
Hypercoagulability can
be either inherited
or acquired and I'm
going to the next
slide I'll show you
some more examples.
And the abnormal blood
flow I should have
mentioned also can cause
endothelial injury.
So these are again of
the virtual triad the
bullet points are
examples of for example
endothelial injury when
we get into the cardiac
system atherosclerosis
hypercholesterolemia
that is all something
that can cause injury
to the endothelium
hypertension diabetes
cigarette smoke we're
going to talk a little
bit about elevated
homocysteine here i already
mentioned the abnormal
blood flow and primary
secondary discerters
and this this lecture
is mostly about the
hypercoagulable state
but i also want to
discuss thrombi and
what they are and
what happens to them
and embolism so just
this should be review
and so i'm going
to go through it a
bit quickly endothelial
injury when the
sub endothelial region
is exposed because
of injury you'll
have von Willebrand
factor and tissue
factor, as we have
discussed, and that
can trigger thrombosis.
Inflammation can
promote thrombosis, and
causes include a lot
of these things listed
here, which you're
going to hear me say
this over and over
again, but keep in mind
that a lot of things
can go wrong. Physical
injury, infectious
agents, abnormal blood,
all these things can
be prothrombotic.
The procoagulant changes,
like the endothelial
cells activated
by, for example,
inflammatory cytokines,
will down-regulate
expression of thrombomodulin,
and why is that
important? Because
the pro-coagulant and
pro-inflammatory actions
of thrombin, which
is very important in
making the thrombus,
is enhanced. And also
the antifabinolytic
effects are also
important as well, because
that favors the
development of thrombi.
Again, going back to
turbulence, abnormal
blood flow, we're in
the second of the three
this again will cause
endothelial injury
as i mentioned and
because why because you
have an area of
turbulence or stasis and
you do not have laminar
blood flow laminar
meaning plates or a
nice flow you will
have a disruption in
the flow and because of
that there will be
endothelial activation
because it's
disrupted and enhances
procoagulant activity
The laminar flow is gone.
And the examples I've
already mentioned,
atherosclerotic plaques
and acute MI, as
well as aneurysms.
Aneurysms are dilatations
of vascular walls,
and also it can happen
in the heart. And you'll
have like an area,
an outpatching, that
can have static stasis
in it. The blood is
not going to be going
as quickly as it's
going everywhere else.
So hypercoagulability,
The third is the
abnormal tendency of
blood to clot. It could
be primary or
secondary. This is very
important in venous
thrombosis, although we
are going to discuss
arterial thrombosis.
And the primary ones
are listed here.
We'll come back to
them in a little bit.
I just want to talk
about thrombosis
itself. What
is it? How does
it look? It really
also depends,
remember, size and
shape and where.
And the big thing
here to remember are
the lines of Zahn.
Lines of Zahn are a
description of both a
gross and microscopic
finding. They're
alternating layers
of pale pink and dark
red, which represent
the pale platelet
and fibrin deposits
along with the red
blood cell ridge.
What it means, if you
have lines of Zahn,
is that the thrombus
formed before death.
It formed in blood
that was flowing.
And this is important
because after death,
post-mortem, you can
get a lot of clots.
Those are non-laminated.
They do not have
layers, especially
when you're looking
for a cause of death.
In autopsies, that's
important to make
sure that you know the
difference between
a post-mortem and an
anti-mortem clot.
The other thing about
thrombi are that
they're attached to the
underlying vascular
surface. If they easily
come out of the
vessel, that's probably
post-mortem when you're
doing an autopsy.
The arterial thrombi,
like I mentioned, the
atherosclerotic
plaques, et cetera, tend
to grow retrograde.
The venous ones in the
direction of blood
flow. The point being
that they both propagate
toward the heart.
And this is what
I mean by lines of
Zahn. Keep this
in mind. And the
one on the left,
the vessel is cut
sagittally, if you
will, or you can
see the cross
-section, I should say.
And on the right,
also, you have
a cross-section,
but you see
the lines of Zahn
longitudinally.
The gross is a little
bit hard to detect,
but you can tell
there's light and dark
layers, and these
are important for
the pathologist,
anyway, to diagnose
a real thrombus.
this is a venous
thrombus which is usually
well venous thrombi of
course have lines of
zon in smaller vessels
in smaller veins I
should say which is less
frequent um that you
can get these things
called red thrombi so
you still have some
kind of a layering but
it's not as distinct
but don't worry too much
about this one this
is the postmortem clot
does not have any lines
of zon as you can see
in the upper picture,
there's just nothing.
There's a bunch of
little cells in there.
The picture on the bottom
is what pathologists
like to call chicken
fat. And again,
this obsession with
food, I cannot explain,
but it's basically very
gelatinous and there's
a dark red portion
and a yellow portion.
And I want to emphasize
again that this is
distinguished from
thrombi in living people
because there is in
this case no um no
lines of zon because
you need flowing blood
for there to be lines
of zon okay so little
discussion so those
are what a thrombi are
from a morphological
point venous and arterial
thrombi and post
-mortem clots i already
mentioned are the
chicken fat the venous
thrombi themselves can
cause painful congestion
edema obviously
distal and they can
embolize the lungs, which
we will discuss later,
and they will form
a cast in the lumen
because the venous
circulation is sluggish.
I mentioned the red
thrombi, and one thing
we'll come back to
is that the lower
extremities, the
veins in the lower
extremities, are most
commonly involved, the
deep venous thrombosis
that we'll talk
about. In the arterial
thrombi, they can
also embolize and cause
downstream infarctions
and they are often
occlusive whereas
the venous ones are
always occlusive.
Most commonly and
most worrisome are the
coronary and cerebral
ones and also femoral
ones. That's a decreasing
order of frequency
because if you block
off a coronary artery
you're going to have
an MI. If you block off
a cerebral artery you
will have a ******.
Again the arterial
cardiac thrombi usually
begin at sites of
turbulence or endothelial
injury. you can
have thrombia in the
heart chambers. They're
known as mural thrombia,
mural meaning wall,
and you can see
them in the MI, as I
mentioned. Now, I keep
saying MI. Abnormal
myocardial contract. In
MI, you have necrotic
heart tissue, right?
A little area or big
area of heart wall
has been infarct, has
no blood supply, and
is necrotic. Therefore,
if it's dead tissue,
it does not contract
like the rest of
the heart wall. So
that's the problem. You
don't have a nice
coordinated contraction.
The arrhythmia, I
already mentioned AFib.
Okay, a little
bit more about
venous thrombosis,
also known as
flebothrombosis.
Most occur either in
the superficial deep
veins of the leg.
The superficial ones
are accustomed to
call them varicosities
and that's where
it's in the saphenous
veins, and they rarely
embolize. It's the
ones that we worry
about that really that
may embolize are the
deep venous thrombus
thrombi, DVTs,
involving the large leg
veins, especially the
popliteal femoral iliac.
These are the ones
we worry about that
embolize through the
lungs and can cause
pulmonary infarction
among other things
like, that's one thing
it can cause, but
pulmonary hemorrhage,
also sudden death.
DVTs also can cause
local pain and they're
down in the leg in
the extremity because
of the venous
obstruction. But because
there's venous
collateral channels,
about half these patients
are not symptomatic.
And only after
the thrombite have
embolized, which means
they've gone to a
different place,
they've broken off and
detached and gone
somewhere else, are they
actually recognized.
And that can be too
late if it causes
his death, obviously.
And these lower extremity
DVTs are associated
with a lot of different
hypercoagulable
states, which we will
discuss. And common
things include bed rest,
any prolonged bed rest,
immobilization on a
long airline trip,
congestive heart failure,
trauma surgery, etc.
Now, I will be
repeating that over
and over again,
because I think
it's important
to keep in mind
whenever you see somebody
in this condition.
This is, again,
venous thrombosis,
usually with stasis.
This is a leg obviously
affected by a deep
vein thrombosis,
and these are the
different things
that I've already
discussed. Keep in
mind obesity and
pregnancy and cancer.
Some cancers,
especially the ones that
produce mucin, like
adenocarcinoma,
will have procoagulants,
as I discussed.
and if that's
released from the
tumor cells, they
can cause thrombi.
Arterial and cardiac
thrombosis, I've
already kind of
beaten to death. The
atherosclerosis, the
myocardial infarction, etc.
Because you've disrupted
the endothelial
integrity or there's
abnormal blood flow
sometimes. So just keep
that, I'm repeating
myself on purpose as I
usually do to keep that
in mind this is a
repetition okay this is
a very busy slide and
it comes from table
one of the tables in
robins and this was a
attempt to list and
they don't make red and
bold things in robins
so i did it myself
primary and secondary
kinds of thrombophilias
or hypercoagulable
states i have highlight
or i should say i've
bolded the ones that
i'm going to really
talk more about in the
primary, the primary
ones at least. And the
secondaries, there's
a whole list of them.
And if you've noticed,
I want you to keep
in mind things like
prolonged bed rest and
cancer. Later on, when
you do cardiac system,
you will remember
the MI and the AFib.
And we're going
to talk about
two other
acquired ones. One
very briefly,
because it's more
pharmacological, and
that's heparin-induced
thrombocytopenia,
which yes, we did talk
about and hemorrhage
and antiphospholipid
antibody syndrome. Also
remember pregnancy and
oral contraceptive use
and smoking as secondary
causes. Okay so again
this is the outline
of primary and
secondary. The secondary
ones that I'll talk
about are HIT and
antiphospholipid
syndrome and keep
in mind all these
others they're just
as important even
though they're in kind
of a one-liner. They're
just as important and
I repeat that again.
So let's go with the
primary ones and these
are inherited. The
first one being factor
V Leiden. This is
not factor, it's not
factor V deficiency,
it's factor V Leiden
which means there's
a mutation in the
factor V and this was
named after I believe
a town or a city in
the Netherlands, in
Holland, somewhere like
that. It is the most
common hereditary
thrombosis syndrome,
occurring in about 2
to 15% of Caucasians.
Autosomal dominant,
but incomplete
penetrance. There's
one single nucleotide
mutation, and because
of that one mutation,
the factor V is
resistant to cleavage and
inactivation by protein
C. So you've lost
an antithrombotic
regulator. In the lower
right-hand corner, I
have a box, which helps
kind of, you realize
that protein C goes
to active protein C.
It needs protein S to
go and inactivate
factor V and VIII, and
so you lose that
antithrombotic regulator.
A person who's a
heterozygote has about five
times increased risk
for venous thrombosis,
and the homozygote's
a lot more, 50 times.
Again, as I mentioned,
they're usually
asymptomatic if they're
heterozygotes, I
should say the factor
5-laden patients.
They may develop
DVTs, though, when
combined with inactivity.
Like if they have
this heterozygosity
and they're in a
prolonged airplane,
it may bring it on.
People who get
recurrent DVTs should be
looked at because this
mutation is present
in nearly 60% of those
types of patients.
and it's important
to keep in mind that
anybody under the age
of 50 especially who has
thrombotic events
should really you should
think about some kind
of inherited clotting
disorder especially
factor five light and if
they happen to be
caucasian um not because
you want to dismiss it
in any other ethnicity
but because they happen
to be more common
two to fifteen percent
caucasian population.
And even if they have
other risk factors,
such as obesity or
prolonged, all those
other things that I
mentioned, you still
have to wonder,
why is this person
clotting? The diagnosis
down there, as it
states, is activated
protein C assay, which
means that there's
failure to prolong
the PTT with the
addition of purified
protein C. But really,
that's not as good
as doing genetic
testing. You really want
to do genetic testing
to bring it home.
Another primary
thrombophilia is
prothrombin or factor
2 gene mutation.
Please do not
memorize G20210A.
That's just telling
you the nucleotide
change, and it's in
the prothrombin gene.
And what happens is
because of it, you get
elevated prothrombin.
This happens in
1 to 2 percent of the
general population
so it's also important
to remember but
it's not as common
okay it's not as common
you'll get these
elevated levels that
of course can be
converted to thrombin
and that's what's
basically uh going to
make a thrombus so
these patients will
have increased risk
and um three times
you don't have to
memorize three times
just realize they
have an increased risk
I want to talk a little
bit about elevated
homocysteine and
endothelial damage. This
will come up again in
the cardiac system.
This can be inherited
or acquired. I know
I'm talking about
the inherited, but
I want to discuss
them kind of together.
Homocysteine, what is
it? It's amino acid
metabolite. It
contributes to
atherosclerosis as well
as arterial and venous
thrombosis. And when
it's elevated often,
that can predict
cardiovascular events,
and you've probably
heard about that.
They believe the
prothrombotic effects are
due to the linkages,
the thiester linkages
formed between the
metabolites of homocysteine
and certain proteins
like fibrinogen.
Like I said, it could be
inherited or acquired.
Inherited would be a
deficiency of cystathione
beta synthetase. The
acquired ones include
deficiencies in
certain vitamins like
vitamin B6, B12, and
folic acid. I think this
is better seen in
this picture. This is
the metabolism of
homocysteine. And as you can
tell, for homocysteine
to go into cysteine,
and there's two
arrows there, you need
that enzyme, CBS,
the cytothionine beta
synthetase. You also need
vitamin B6. And all of
this is dependent, I
mean, this whole thing
is dependent on each
other. If you don't
have that enzyme,
you're going to have a
buildup of homocysteine.
If you don't have
vitamin b6 or b12 or
the others you also will
have a buildup of
homocysteine and other
causes include these
things listed like renal
failure and diabetes
another primary
thrombophilia is antithrombin
3 deficiency it's
rare what is antithrombin
3 i want to remind
you do normally it
inhibits thrombin and
factor 10. So that's
another regulator of
clot formation and it's
enhanced by heparin.
When you don't have
enough that will increase
the thrombin and
increase thrombosis.
Most likely if it is
genetic it's going to
be and like I said
it's rare it's going
to be autosomal dominant
although there are
autosomal recessive
ones and the type 1
it means that there's
not enough made and
type 2 means there's
a defective protein.
When it's acquired, okay,
when it's
acquired, because
we talked about
the inherited,
it means there's either
liver disease or,
and I put it in red,
nephrotic syndrome,
which will become
important again in the
future when we talk
about the renal system.
The nephrotic
syndrome, which we have
a lot of proteinuria,
is associated
with antithrombin 3
deficiency. That's
not the only association,
but when that
comes up, you'll
see the association.
Again, what we're
talking about is the
presentation of venous
thrombosis. I'm not
going to go into the
therapeutics. Basically,
you want to break up
the clots or clot.
Protein C and S
deficiency, I'll say
together, because as
you can see in the
lower right-hand
corner, they kind
of rely on each other.
At least you need
protein S for
active protein C to
go and inactivate
the factors 5 and 8.
Normally, they're
anticoagulants and they're
made by the liver. they're
vitamin k dependent
um the protein s is a
cofactor for protein
c that's what it
should say in there um
and it reduces thrombin
generation so without
it as i'm as we had
mentioned earlier with
factor five the mutation
results in about
inability to inactivate
those factors and you
get more thrombin
formations there's also an
increased risk of
thrombotic skin necrosis
i should say people
who have this also have
an increased risk of
thrombotic skin necrosis
with warfarin i'm not
going to get too much
into this this is
more of a pharmacology
thing but if you put
a patient on warfarin
the liver will not
produce factors 27910 or
protein cns because
they come from the liver
all pro pre-existing
protein cns will degrade
first and leave the
pre-existing factors
to be high i and the
big thing again venous
thrombosis and recurrent
thromboembolism,
especially in adolescence
and early adulthood.
Okay,
again with the
secondary or acquired
hypercoagula, I've
mentioned them a
few times. Please
look at this list.
Realize that you're
going to come up with
many patients who
have all these things
that may be wrong and
you want to, you know,
this is why people
who are heavier, they
have a larger BMI or
in prolonged bedrifts
will get blood thinners
or anticoagulants.
Though two down there
in dark, in bold
I should say, are the
ones that I want to
point out. The HIT
we've already discussed,
and I'm not going to
go into detail, but
I want you to know
these are secondary
causes of hypercoagulability
or thrombus
formation. We already
talked about HIT in
bleeding because it
causes thrombocytopenia.
and it can also
cause thrombosis,
and that's a very serious
complication in
about half the cases.
You make the
diagnosis by showing
antibodies against
PF4, which is
platelet factor 4
heparin complex.
It can present this
whole thing with onset
of pain, redness,
swelling, or these other
things like necrosis
of skin, ******, or MI.
We already talked
about two types, and
it's the type 2 that
we're most concerned
about. That's the
immune-mediated one.
and this is a nice
pictorial I think it's
from Robbins and it
helps visualize what's
going on you the antibodies
form form and they
recognize the complex
um heparin uh the pf4
heparin or heparin pf4
complex and how the
um this leads to
platelet activation and
aggregation and you can
see from the picture,
it can be low plates
or thrombocytopenia
because all the
platelets are removed by
the splenic
macrophages or platelet
activation could cause
platelet aggregation and
you get thrombosis.
So this is just a
nice visual of that
and I'm not going to
say anything more
about it. I want to say
that antiphospholipid
antibody syndrome is
extremely complex
and I'm not going to
go through it in three
slides very, very
thoroughly, but I want
you to know this is
another acquired thing
that can, I'm sorry,
this is another
thing that can cause
thrombosis, and it's
considered acquired.
It is autoimmune.
You make the
diagnosis because you
have the presence of
the antiphospholipid
autoantibodies,
and I'll talk to
you in a second
about what they are.
as well as venous
arterial thrombosis.
Sometimes, especially
in females,
you'll get pregnancy
complications.
Secondary causes of
antiphospholipidic
syndrome include things
like lupus. People
with lupus may have
this syndrome as well,
whereas people who
have primary APS,
they're going to have
a hypercoagulable state
but no evidence of
autoimmune disease.
Some of the antiphospholipid
autoantibodies
include the three in
the bullets here, anti
-cardiolipin, anti
-beta-2-glycopartine I,
and something called
lupus anticoagulants.
Again, we're going
to talk about
recurrent thromboses,
but in this
case also repeated
miscarriages,
cardiac valve vegetations,
and thrombocytopenia.
Also pulmonary
embolism if they get
DVTs, which can cause
pulmonary hypertension
and valvular heart
disease, etc. So a
lot of different things
can go wrong here.
So the pathogen,
this is not fully
understood, and
you'll see why
in a second. It's
very complex.
The antibodies are
directed against the
anionic membrane
phospholipids, or proteins
that are associated
with the phospholipids.
Anti-beta-2-glycoprotein
antibodies are
supposed to have a major
role in this because
they activate endothelial
cells, monocytes,
and platelets. and
patients with this
show also evidence of
complement activation
and inhibition of
fibrinolytic processes
both of which will go
towards the prothrombotic
state. I put in red
something important
because the pregnancy
morbidity the loss
of the miscarriages is
a defining manifestation
of APS. One of
my friends during
pathology residency had
three or four miscarriages
before they made
this diagnosis of
antiphospholipid syndrome.
And I just want to
impress upon you that
the fetal loss in
this case, early fetal
loss, is not thought
to be caused by
actual thrombosis,
even though this is
a thrombotic disease,
but actually from
antibody-mediated
interference with the
growth and differentiation
of trophoblasts,
which are part of
the placental cells
and so the placenta
does not form or
there's no placentation.
Now people who
don't have the
syndrome, about five
to fifteen percent
of them may test
positive. There
are false positives
in this disease.
This is also kind of
paradoxical but
the antibodies
induce the hypercoagulable
state in vivo.
So these people are
prone to thrombi. But
in vitro, in the lab,
in the test tubes,
they interfere with
the phospholibids and
they inhibit coagulation.
So they will have
a prolonged PTT, which
is something to keep
in the back of your
mind. And if you mix
patient plasma with
controlled plasma, then
the PTT will not
correct. Again, because
we're talking about
autoimmunity here
people can have a
false positive test for
******** and um that's
something to keep in
mind if somebody does
not have a history
of ******** or says
they have not had any
******** uh you may
want to look at this
as a that it may be a
false positive i don't
know the percentage
but i don't think
it's a high percentage
and part of the reason
is because um the
antibodies cross-react
with the phospholipids
of the organism
that causes ********,
which is streponema.
And you have to, as
I said, look for the
antibodies, and you're
going to want to
get rid of the thrombi
with anticoagulation,
which I'll leave to
the pharmacology.
Now this is what I
was talking about,
very complex. This
is one of the simpler
ones I could find
about antiphospholipid
syndrome. I believe
this comes from Canada,
and there's just so
much going on here,
not just thrombosis,
fetal loss, other
findings as you can
see. I do not want
you to memorize this,
but it kind of puts
together on one page
all the stuff that's
going on that they
understand, okay?
So again, don't memorize
this, but realize
anticoidal syndrome
is not just a
thrombotic syndrome.
There are other things
going on because
of the antibodies.
And once again, other
secondary causes
we talked about
over before are
these things keep
them in your mind
also I don't know if
I mentioned a hyper
viscosity like
polycythemia vera because
the blood is if you
will thicker and
slower moving so you
get stasis and people
who are older tend
to have reduced
endothelial PGI 2
production so that's
another thing to keep
in mind so please look
at this list remember
your patients who
are on oral
contraceptives, who are on
prolonged bed rest,
malignancies, etc.
Here's a question that
I got from osmosis,
which I understand
is a very popular
site, and it is an
example. I did adapt
it because I changed
the question a little
bit, but the explanations
are the same.
This is a 25, if
you want to read it,
stop the tape and
read it, that's fine.
The 25-year-old
Caucasian woman presents
to the ED. She's having
trouble breathing.
Two hours ago, she
had chest pain with
the stismia. She
doesn't have any trauma
recently or smoke
or use drugs or is
on any contraceptive
pills. This is all
important information
here that you want
to gather. She does
not have a fever.
She's distressed,
obviously because she can't
breathe her heart
and lungs um physical
exam are normal and the
labs show an elevated
d-dimer remember elevated
d-dimer and um it's
not just uh dic so
just keep this in mind
pt and ptt are
respectively 12
and 10 which
means the pt is
normal but the
ptt is decreased
which is kind of odd.
When they add
purified protein C to
the patient's plasma,
it does not change
the PTT. It doesn't
change a lot of
values, which means
the PT stays normal,
PTT does not
prolong. And what did
I say before about
PT not prolonging?
I said back here,
if we go back to it.
Okay, I will get back to
oh it goes all the way
back never mind i'll
bring it to you in
a second the pt does
not prolong is something
i mentioned about
the apl antibodies
right or that they
should be prolonged in
in the apl so keep that
in the in the back
of your mind when
you're looking at
the answers in
antiphospholiposome
it you should
have prolonged ptt
but you don't here
so that's already
eliminated. Okay, that's
what I was trying to
get at. In antiphospholipid
syndrome, you
should have prolonged
PTT because of the in
vitro paradoxical
thing that's going on.
So what other
choice could it be?
Just think about it.
And the answer is
E, as in Edward, Factor
V Leiden deficiency.
I shouldn't say
Factor V Leiden
deficiency. I should
say Factor V Leiden
because it really
shouldn't, you'd mention
the mutation. I guess
it is a deficiency,
but technically I just
call it factor V Leiden
because the factor
V is working, right?
So it's there, but
it's not, it's mutated.
So this is factor V
because Leiden, because
even when you add the
um the purified protein
c it does not change
um the pt does not
prolong it it stays down
okay so that's great
what what about the
others so protein s
could it could be protein
s it could be protein
c and it even these
answers came directly
from the site but again
we're talking about
something that's rare
than factor five light
and there was an
important reason why we
just got the word the
woman was labeled as
Caucasian not that this
doesn't happen in any
other ethnicity but
that was kind of a hint
because it is you know
higher percentage in
Caucasians there's also
it's not prothrombin
gene mutation there's
failure to change
the PTT and this one
as well it's and we
discussed antiphospholipid
syndrome and it's not
antithrombic deficiency.
I will let you
read through these
explanations, but the
important thing to come
from this question is
that what we're dealing
with is a young woman
who should not be having
a DVT and a pulmonary
embolism, and who
does. She has no
other risk factors. She
does not seem to have
lupus or anything
like that, and so the
most common reason
would be factor V laden.
Or if you want to
say factor V laden
deficiency, that's
fine. and it's
just that the factor
V is there, it's
just mutated, so
it's not working.
So what happens
to a thrombus?
I mean, does it always
just occlude the vessels?
No.
There's four different
things. It can
get bigger and
bigger and bigger,
causing cold propagation,
which means it
will eventually
occlude the vessel.
It can embolize, and
the reason why that's
in red is because
that's what I'm going to
discuss in the next few
slides. It can go away.
It can dissolve. it
can resolve because of
fibrinolysis so it
can get shrunken and
disappear and one of the
reasons why we want to
use TPA in the early
very early on is that
in the older thrombi
they have much more
fibrin deposition and
cross-linking and they're
more resistant to lysis
so you need it early
in the first few
hours or it can also
organize and recanalize
where the older thrombi
can become organized by
ingrowth of endothelial
cells and smooth
muscles and fibroblasts
and they'll get little
capillary channels
that form inside the
thrombus and actually
allow the blood to
continue to flow and what
do i mean by that okay
so over here on the
left is resolution you've
got it's completely
gone and everything
everybody's happy again
embolism in this case
this is going to the
lung which we'll discuss
in a second this is
where it gets organized
and incorporated for
example into the vessel
wall. And this is
what we mean by
recanalization. It was
thrombotic. I mean, it
was occlusive, but it now
has these little
channels. And you can see
this on this picture
better. These are examples
of how recanalization
works. This is a low
power. And you can
see the little areas
here where you're starting
to get endothelial
growth and you end up
with this. So what was
once one big vessel is
now one, two, three,
four, five little
ones. So it's not as
effective, but the blood
flow is going through.
Embolism is really
the last thing we
want to discuss, and
it's anything that
breaks off or is
detached from a
thrombus. And that
could be a solid thing,
a gaseous liquid
from the point of
origin to the distant
site. and that will
cause tissue problems
or infarction.
Most of the time
we're talking about
thromboembolism, dislodged
thrombi, but we will
just briefly discuss
other things that might
embolize. Anything that's
in your bloodstream
that comes off of
another place is an
embolist, but mainly
they're thromboembolism.
So the emboli go on
to travel through the
blood, eventually
reach vessels that they
can't get through,
and cause partial or
complete occlusion. So
these are the main types
of emboli that we're
going to go through.
Obviously, the first
two are really the
most common, thrombotic
ones, thromboembolism,
and the others come
in less frequency.
So one of the most
common thromboembolism
we kind of had in the
question, pulmonary
thromboembolism, is
going to be fully
discussed in respiratory
system. But basically
what you have is the
blood flow to the
pulmonary artery is
disrupted and also, or
it could be one of
the branches, because
most of the time a DVT
from the deep veins
of the lower extremities
has embolized.
It's broken off.
And about 95%
lower extremities,
especially the
popliteal fossa.
from the question
you could tell that
dyspnea and pleuritic
chest pain cough all
these things hemoptysis
can be signs of
pulmonary embolism now
it's not always severe
and it's not always
fatal and that we'll
discuss a little bit
more in the respiratory
system but I just want
to this is a picture
over on the right.
This is what's known
as a saddle embolus,
which kind of makes
a saddle between the
main bifurcation here,
straddles the
bifurcation, if you will.
As I mentioned,
these usually come
from the DVTs, and what
they do is they fragment
off, and they just
go into larger veins
to the right heart, and
then boom, because of
the way it travels to
the system, blood system,
you're going to go
into the lungs and
then it's going to slam
into the lungs. And it
could include a very
large artery, which
is not good, which is
probably sudden death
or maybe sudden death,
I should say. And that's
the saddle, you see
the saddle embolism, or
it can go into smaller
vessels, arteries
and things like that.
You can get multiple
ones of these or a
shower of them and the
important thing to remember
is most of them are
clinically silent
that doesn't mean
they're not they're great
I mean it just means
that because they can
lead to pulmonary
hypertension because they
narrow the cross
-sectional area of the
vasculature in the lung
so the major consequences
of pulmonary embolism
especially when you
have 60 or more the
pulmonary circulation
blocked off, is sudden
death as I mentioned,
acute right heart
failure known
as core pulmonary
or just collapse
of the cardiovascular
system.
You can also get pulmonary
hemorrhage, usually
not pulmonary infarct
if it's a medium
-sized artery, reason
being that the lung has
two vessels, it's two
supplies, two arterial
supplies, pulmonary
and bronchial, and
so if you have an intact
bronchial circulation
that can make up for
the fact that the
pulmonary circulation
has been compromised.
And if you have
multiple emboli, as I
mentioned, you will
reduce the cross
-sectional areas of
the vessels and you'll
get eventually
pulmonary hypertension,
another topic for the
respiratory system.
Systemic thromboembolism
arise in or
affect the arterial
system. Two-thirds
are associated with
MIs, left ventricular
wall infarcts, and
one-fourth with
atrial dilation and
fibrillation, which
we had said before,
afibrillation.
You can get
paradoxical emboli.
Sometimes we just don't
know where they come.
Please keep in mind
that arterial emboli
can travel to many
sites versus the venous
thrombi, most of which
travel to the lung,
right because of the
way the blood flow
through the body most
of the arterial emboli
will go to the lower
extremities or brain
or things like the
intestines kidney
spleens okay although
the venous thrombi
usually go from the
legs to the lung most of
the time not always the
systemic thromboembolism
the arterial ones
usually result
in infarction of tissue
because the tissue
is not getting the
blood supply. Therefore,
it's not getting the
oxygen. It should.
This is a paradoxical
emboli. It's called
paradoxical because
it's not what you would
think of the way the blood
flow goes. It's rare,
obviously, and for it
to happen, you need
to have a septal defect.
This is a congenital
heart defect in the
atrium or the ventricle
as seen here anatomically.
That's all want
to mention about that
atherosclerotic emboli
are kind of interesting
this is like you
can get little emboli
a little detached
fragments of atherosclerotic
plaques that go off
and block vessels
and this occurs when
atheromatous plaques in
very large arteries release
cholesterol emboli
and other debris into
circulation and this
could happen also
especially in intra
-arterial procedures, actual
procedures that they're
trying to get rid of
the plaque or something
like that. What you
see here in the upper
right are cholesterol
clefts or crystals,
those are those spaces,
the lines if you will,
the asterix is there
and you get a
hyperplastic tissue
around it intimal,
the intima is the
inner region of the
vessel and giant
cells which you
can't really see
here because this
is a lower power.
Okay a little bit about
fat bone marrow and
fat and bone marrow
embolism. When you
have fat globules and
sometimes associated
with the marrow, the
hematopoietic marrow,
this can be problematic.
And why can this
happen? It can get into
the vasculature after
fractures, especially
of long bones, like
femur, for example.
And the fat in the
bone marrow, because
there is fat in the bone
marrow, especially as
you get older, will
be released into the
vascular sinusoids.
The fat microemboli
and red cell and
platelet aggregates
actually include pulmonary
and cerebral
micro... or they can,
pulmonary and cerebral
with consequences.
The pathogenesis
involves both
mechanical
obstruction and
biochemical injury.
Mechanically,
the RBCs and platelets
are aggregated by
fat that can obstruct,
as I said just now,
the pulmonary and
cerebral microvascular.
or biochemical injury
because of the toxicity
to the endothelium
from the free fatty
acids okay and what you
see in these pictures
are just the round
holes that look empty
that's the fat and
you can see there's
a little bit of marrow
sometimes now why
would you know the
marrow the fat's coming
from the marrow i have
seen this in um in
autopsies in the lung
also from very aggressive
cpr when the
sternum breaks, and
sometimes it happens,
in which case the person
has died of an MI,
not of this, but these
can happen with very
aggressive CPR as well,
but usually fractures
of the lung bones.
There is something
called fat embolism
syndrome, which is not
usually what happens.
It's in the minority
of patients where you
have pulmonary
insufficiency, neurological
problems, anemia,
and thrombocytopenia.
In this syndrome,
you also develop a
very diffuse
petechial rash, and it
is fatal in about
5 to 15% of cases.
The thrombocytopenia
occurs because the
platelet adhesions, the
fat globules, and the
aggregation, also because
of splenic sequestration,
and the anemia can
result from either
the red cell aggregation
or hemolysis. This
usually happens one to
three days after the
injury, like a large
femur fracture, and
the person will develop
a very sudden onset
of tachypnea, dyspnea,
tachycardia, and it
can go on to neurological
delirium and coma.
Air embolism is
important, especially,
well, it's important
in a lot of things. It
can happen, but when we
think of decompression
syndrome this comes
up. What happens
with air embolism is
that when you have
communication between
the vasculature and
the outside air
you have a negative
pressure gradient that
***** in air. How does
air get into the
vasculature? Well it can
be introduced
during procedures,
endovascular
procedures, even
mechanical ventilation
and you need a
large volume of air.
More than 100 millimeters
can cause pulmonary
circulation effects.
If you get 300, 500
quickly, that can be
fatal. So there's a
list of things that
can cause air embolism.
And remember,
these are very
rare in these
things, but coronary
bypass, laparoscopic
surgery,
central line placement,
all these things
listed. And I will
discuss the decompression
syndrome in a second
in the next slide.
The air in the pulmonary
vasculature will
block perfusion going
downstream and the
microemboli of the air
trapped in the pulmonary
capillaries will
cause an inflammatory
response very intense
that when you have
inflammation you get
the cytokines release
and that injures the
alveoli in the lungs.
These bubbles
in the central
nervous system
can also cause
mental impairment
and a coma.
Classically this is
not a good thing.
Sudden collapse may
happen, neurologic symptoms
that mimic
******, apnea, and
cardiovascular collapse.
So a little word on
decompression sickness,
if you ever have gone
deep sea diving,
which you won't find
me doing, but anyway,
if you ever do, it
is a form of gas
embolism when patients
have a sudden decrease
in atmospheric
pressure. So this can
happen in scuba divers.
When the air is
breathed at high
pressures, when you
go down really deep,
the increased amounts
of gas, especially
nitrogen, get dissolved
in blood and tissues.
But if the diver
ascends really quickly,
you have to come up
slowly, the nitrogen
will come out of
solution and go into the
blood and tissues. And
when you have these gas
bubbles rapidly
forming in the skeletal
muscles and around
the joints, you get
something called the
bends or pains in these
places. And if they're
in the lungs, the gas
bubbles will cause
edema, hemorrhage,
ephysema, things
like that,
atelectasis,
which is focal
collapse of the
lung. And that's the
chokes, respiratory
distress.
A chronic form of
decompression sickness
is known as caisson
disease, where you have
the persistence of gas
emboli in the skeletal
system where you
get many different
foci of ischemic
necrosis, especially the
femoral heads and areas
mentioned here. I put
the next bullet in
a separate area down
the bottom because
that really refers to
how they treat acute
decompression sickness
with putting
someone in a chamber
under high enough
pressure to force
the gas bubbles
back into solution.
And lastly amniotic
fluid embolism.
I have never seen
this but this is
not this is can be
very very serious.
It is the fifth
most common cause
of maternal mortality
in the world
and it can also
result in permanent
neurological deficit
in the mother.
You know incidents
can vary it depends
depending on the
book you read but it
is the point to
take here is that a
mortality rate is
very high, very high.
The woman, the mother
will have sudden severe
dyspnea, cyanosis and
shock, neurological
impairment. It could
be a seizure, coma,
and DIC. Why does this
cause morbidity and
mortality? For a number
of reasons. Biochemically,
you activate the
coagulation factors,
also the immune system,
the innate parts of
the immune system. And
the important thing
here is that there's a
release of vasoactive
substances, which
means that the vessels,
there's an intense
vasoconstriction in the
pulmonary circulation.
What happens when you
have an intense
vasoconstriction in the
pulmonary circulation is
that you get pulmonary
hypertension and
something known as core
pulmonality or right
heart failure, as well
as DIC. So that's
what's the issue here,
rather than the
obstruction of the amniotic
fluid embolus. This all
leads to hypoxia, left
heart failure, because
right heart failure
and left heart failure
often go hand in
hand, and lung damage
as well. This is what
you might see. The
underlying cause is infusion
of the amniotic fluid
or fetal tissue into
the maternal
circulation. So there's a
problem with the mother
via a tear in the
placental membranes or
even rupture of the urine
vein. So this is going
to be you know in
a troublesome labor
delivery situation and
then you get the amniotic
fluid and the feet
now in the amniotic
fluid there's going to
be fetal elements
meaning like the squamous
cells off the surface
of the the fetus or
the baby are going to
be in there so this
debris will eventually
get caught up in the
pulmonary circulation
and this one is what you
might find on autopsy
this purple like kind
of layered stuff there
are squamous cells
are known as epithelial
squames from the
fetal skin there's also
could be lanugo hair
which is a type of very
light hair and on the
baby other things
vernix cassiosa these
all these things can
cause our debris that can
cause this kind of
problem where you get
the amniotic fluid embolism
this is the summary
slide that was very
long. If you have
any questions please
feel free to reach me and
I thank you very much
for your attention.